Hello everybody, this is Dr. Kevin Cutters tackling some of the biggest questions that we receive
This question is always a very serious one. What if it's the testicized?
What if my cancer isn't just stage one anymore? What if they told me it's stage four? What if I'm already in hospice?
What if my mom is laying in a hospital bed in the middle of the living room?
Is there still hope? That's a great question
So the question really is can I still get care?
So the answer is yes, so
Understand from a from a natural perspective. We're treating the patient. We're not treating cancer
So even if the cancer has metastasized our protocol. Yes, it's going to look a little bit different than if you're in stage one
We may be a little more aggressive, but the right frequencies will still work
They're going to go across your whole body
So it's not just specific to that one location
So if you have breast cancer that's metastasized to the liver and the lungs, it's still breast cancer in the liver and the lungs
It's not liver cancer and lung cancer. It's still that those breast cancer cells that have metastasized through
Circulated to ourselves to a different part of the body
So when we use right frequencies or we use nutrition and we're using diet
It's still going to affect that cancer anywhere in the body
So you don't need to worry. What we're going to be doing is going to be hitting that cancer and stimulating your immune system
So your body will help attack that cancer no matter where it is. So yes, you can still get care
And yes, it still does work just a side note
The majority of people that come to us are stage four and again, we're not oncologists
We're not treating cancer. We're treating the patient. I wish more people found out they had cancer and then they decide
To do an alternative protocol maybe along with conventional medicine as well
But but most people don't and I know some people just got diagnosed with cancer
It's already in a later stage and they're searching for help. We want to help people wherever they are
We also tell people don't ever get my hope
We've had patients stage four cancer that were given two weeks to live live years longer
Everything we do isn't magic. We're trusting God in all our decision making process
Literally we're praying over our cheek swabs and testing before we do any of it
So you can always still get care you always still have hope
Does alternative care still work in later stages? Yes
It can so when you strengthen the body and you strengthen yourselves
It's always going to be better than if you are just doing standards of care or you're just trying to manage it
The things that got you to where you're at right now we have to make some changes
We need to support your body to build it back up to be able to heal your body
And certainly I would never try treating cancer without the use of a right machine
What's your success rate? That's a common question we get
Unfortunately, it's not a question we can answer. There's legal guidelines that we have to follow
We're not treating cancer. We're not keeping success rates
And I know everybody wants to know I don't want to do anything unless there's what what's the chance of this working
The only honest answer to that is I don't know we are in God's hands
I believe my days were numbered before the foundations of the earth were set
It's by responsibility to do everything I possibly can but I don't know
What is going to work and what's not going to work? We just have to do everything we possibly can
Bottom line is there still hope that's really what everybody are looking for there is a lot of hope
Do not believe what if somebody told you a timeline you just have to get that out of your head you just got to
Just erase that ask for God to erase that from your mind. There's always hope
He's sovereign over all things and he knows what's going on and we need to just follow him
And that's really what we ask our patients to do pray about whether this is the right thing for you
Know that we're gonna be praying for you no better what decision you make even if you don't come here
There's always hope we just gotta put our hope in the right place